[Music]
tyler's in state college pennsylvania hi
tyler how are you
hey dave doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up
yeah so my question is related to
business and checking accounts i'm a
business owner i've always operated my
business out of a business checking
account along with a business debit card
as the business scaled up over the years
my expenses are becoming a little bit
higher and more frequent and my current
card only has a 2500 limit um and
each time that i go above that i get a
call into the bank and each time they're
really pressing me on the business
credit card um and just today when i
went to do it they actually denied it
all together and weren't going to let me
do it unless i upgraded to their
business credit card so i guess my
question is um what do you recommend
that like how are you running your
business being like a multi-million
dollar business and all that what's your
recommendation there
uh it's time to change banks dude
yeah that's what i'm thinking yeah
see they got confused
about who the customer is
the customer was sitting in front of
them telling them what he wanted and
they start putting demands on you on how
you're going to use your money
in order to have the privilege of doing
business with these doofuses i'm out of
there man the spirit on that is pitiful
yeah
i don't care even if it wasn't in
violation of what i teach just the way
they treated you today dude
right
that's what i'm talking about so here's
what we've had to do we've got i think
uh
lord i've lost count because i don't
keep up with it daily anymore i used to
be real concerned with it but i think
we've got 150 people carrying debit
cards out of our thousands
um
and a whole bunch of others that have
access to the numbers in order to do
orders with you know around here for
business purposes so
um you know we've got a bunch of them i
obviously have a business debit card on
this place and the revenues here north
of 300 million a year so
um
i i have low tolerance for trying to use
that card and it not buying whatever the
flip i wanted to buy okay yeah i mean so
uh i've we've had discussions with the
business banking
unit
um here and said look uh my card i'm not
i mean you can put ten thousand dollar
twenty thousand dollar limit on it the
number of times i'm gonna buy a car on a
car it's zero anyway so i don't really
have anything i don't i don't don't buy
uh stuff like that all the time but i
also don't wanna not have access to
money when i've got millions of dollars
in your bank that will piss me off
because of your little debit card rules
but uh so we've had on my personal debit
card from the business had them give a
special dispensation
they should do that for you
um and you know 2500 is ridiculous it
ought to be at least five
and um the and you can look at it and
you'll probably be surprised the number
of times you go above five unless you're
doing a bunch of travel or something is
unusual anyway
yeah yeah
so unusually low so um yeah you need to
change banks based on that spirit
but uh you know we've got different
uh people inside this you know for
instance if one of our live event
producers is going to book a block of
rooms you know we're going into a hyatt
and we're going to take down 150 rooms
and they want a card well obviously
you know a daily limit is going to be a
problem on that so you know we and
that's how we use our debit cards here
so we we have some interaction with the
bank on a regular basis but we also have
uh higher than normal limits on some of
the daily amounts and total amounts on
the cards
obviously the cash has to be in the
account to coverage as a debit card um
that's not what we're discussing here
but i think more than anything else what
you're discovering is you have a bank
that doesn't understand your value as a
customer and you need to find one that
does value you by the way we did change
banks and one of the reasons was the
old bank that i've been with for a
thousand years uh got bought up and
bought up a bunch of stuff and became
much more corporatized and became
inflexible
even with an account our size they
started giving us a hard time on all
kinds of different things and we're just
like you know what
i'm not negotiating with you people
you're just a foo flipping bank i mean
there's one on every corner there's a
lot of would like to have our account a
lot of them like to have your account
tyler i'd go get somebody else what are
you thinking i think i think you're
absolutely right you know it's your
money and uh these are somebody made a
decision on the 5th or 6th or 15th or
25th floor
and
i think the spirit is absolutely
it's wrong they don't want to help you
grow
they just got their rules and i'd take
off i'd go talk to some other bank and
go hey here's the deal here's what i'm
looking for and and look them in the eye
and uh interview them interview banks
just like you would
like one of our elps i'm getting ready
to hire you for my banking services yeah
i'm a small business are you good enough
yeah stay out of my way can you let me
do my thing if so i'll bring my money to
you what's happening is this that guy's
dealing with a branch manager who's got
pressure on him to meet the quota that a
certain
he has to move a certain number of
credit cards certain number of business
credit cards a month and he's got people
breathing down his neck he's got a quota
like he's
selling encyclopedias door-to-door
exactly right and these bankers have
been reduced to use car salesmen yeah
these car salesmen are much better
people and so uh sorry about that used
car guys you guys are excellent compared
but i mean they've been reduced to sales
people that have quotas yep i mean if
you work in victoria's secret and you
don't sell a lot of small underwear
that's not what they get gauge you on
you can sell no small underwear and work
at victoria's secret as long as you sell
as long as you sell their credit card
because that's what they want oh they
want you charging small underwear okay i
didn't know where we were going with
this i was i was waiting to see what was
telling you this is it is it's
victoria's secret they are in the v they
are in the credit card business there's
always
retail i mean it's just you know
there's just nothing there there's there
it's just it's the same thing with most
of these companies yeah you go in a
department store why do you think
they're pushing the card on you they
make more money on that they do the
stinking merchandise it's absolutely on
their shelf it's become that credit card
game and that's what these guys are
doing this stupid bank here yeah this
bank deserves a good firing hmm
i like it you're fired yeah
plenty of banks by the way i i tell you
what you know i would i would go
interview the smaller banks yeah you're
bad as bank of america i'll just bet you
oh should i ask him yeah i bet you it's
bank of america it's that's the way they
act it's a big bank or big earth yeah
it's not it's not a small local bank
a small local bank would actually care
what you think yep and uh that's what
you need to go with by the way get you a
good regional bank or small level that's
one thing too we moved to a we moved to
a local that's what we did and they can
handle us i mean
we we got a lot of money over there but
they can handle it so yeah that's not
like
mr
like jed klamat and mr drysdale or
something but um y'all don't even know
who that is out there you poor people in
america
your television deficit
you don't know about the beverly
hillbillies i i feel so happy right now
that you just said mr drysdale kelly's
feeling the same thing we're the same
age we're not going to say the age so
kelly doesn't hit me after the show's
over
i know i know you're a little bit older
but mr drysdale that is classic tv right
there that's classic i mean but i mean
that's a banker who was beholden to the
rich oil barrier
in the beverly hillbillies okay and he
ran around all the time trying to make
his customer happy that's what you want
it's been since the 1950s and 60s with
black and white tv since bankers
understood what their freaking job was
that's so good and it's not to sell you
a credit card that's supposed to make
you the depositor happy yeah oh man
what a lost world we live in i know i'm
going to go home and watch the beverly
hillbillies it's got to be on there i've
got two references to them in three
hours you have have you seen a show
lately no it's when you were channeling
i'm having flashbacks okay from my
childhood that's all it is it's an old
man thing
the old man flashbacks